now to Italy in the latest on a deadly
shipwreck at Sea the boat carrying up to
200 migrants broke apart yesterday near
the tip of Italy more than 60 children
and adults were killed at least 80
others were rescued at least one person
is charged with migrant trafficking Seth
Doan has more
Bree buffeted by rough Seas washed up
and was strewn across this beach in
southern Italy evidence of the tragic
end to this journey
following the Shipwreck some huddled in
blankets as First Responders searched
for survivors and collected the Dead
migrants believe to be mostly from
Afghanistan Pakistan and Iran set out
from turkey last week in a wooden boat
said to be operated by traffickers they
were spotted by the European Union's
border agency over the weekend but a
patrol dispatch to intercept them turned
back due to rough weather
Pope Francis offered prayer Sunday
thanking Rescuers and those who quote
give welcome the incident also whipped
up political debate Italy's Prime
Minister Giorgio Maloney expressed
sorrow for lives broken by traffickers
her right-wing coalition government has
taken a tough stand on migrants adding
new hurdles for Charities trying to
rescue them moves that have been
criticized by the United Nations
it's a day of grief for Calabria the
governor of this Southern Italian region
said adding calabriel welcomes people
but we cannot be abandoned by Europe
around 105 000 migrants came to Italy in
2022 that's roughly 38 000 more than the
year before Italy a regular destination
for migrants trying to reach Europe has
pushed other countries to do more for
CBS morning's Seth Doan Rome